hi i'm christine goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
attorney general william barr stepping
down following criticism from president
trump and his supporters
for refusing to back allegations of
election fraud
former federal prosecutor jim trustee
weighs in on barr's departure
and what it means for the department of
justice and the trump campaign's ongoing
election challenges
president-elect joe biden campaigning in
georgia this week
for democratic senate candidates ahead
of the state's runoffs which will
determine which
party controls the senate arnin mishkin
director of the fox news decision desk
discusses the amount of money being
pumped into these key races
and which party's candidates have the
advantages plus commentary from
syndicated columnist cal thomas
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm dana parino i'm brian kilmeade i'm
shannon breme and this is the fox news
rundown
[Music]
wednesday december 16th 2020
i'm dave anthony the attorney general is
on his way out
after upsetting trump supporters
downplaying election fraud
and not revealing a hunter biden probe
before the election
i find it you know kind of amazing that
people are turning on them yeah it would
have been nice politically for the
president
for the hunter biden story to be
actually covered by the media
but that's no fault of bar he did the
exact right thing on not
releasing information about a pending
case i'm lisa brady
the president-elect hits the campaign
trail in georgia where a crucial battle
for the u.s
senate is underway his life as president
gets easier if the democrats control the
senate
and i'm cal thomas i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
next wednesday will be attorney general
bill barr's last day on the job
departing four weeks before the
president leaves office
and while he was praised in a trump
tweet for doing an outstanding
job the president was said to be upset
over barr's handling of the election
and hunter biden whose foreign business
dealings are now part of a federal
investigation
into his taxes and an undisclosed income
from biden's time on a ukrainian natural
gas company's board
during the campaign joe biden denied his
son
was corrupt my son has not made money
in terms of this thing about what are
you talking about
china and in the second debate he said
the only wrongdoing in ukraine
got president trump impeached trying to
bribe
the ukrainian government to say
something negative about me
president trump told fox's brian
kilmeade over the weekend
joe biden lied on the debate stage he
said there's nothing happening nothing
happening and bill
barr should have stepped up but we
didn't find out until after the election
about that federal investigation
the biggest question mark in terms of
the timing of his leaving is hunter
biden
jim trustee is a former department of
justice prosecutor now a partner at the
ifra law firm in washington
what's interesting to me is this whole
situation where hunter biden
is leaking the information about you
know what he euphemistically says
looking at his taxes
and there's going to be a transition at
the department of justice and so the
question is going to be you know how
much does that case
continue to move forward is there
something in the makings before the end
of the year by way of a guilty plea for
instance or an indictment or a special
counsel
uh appointments there's a lot to look at
in terms of hunter biden and it's an
interesting
moment for the the captain of the ship
to step down right this minute
let's get into this hunter biden story
though it
really came to light even more so
in october with this laptop reported to
be left in delaware
and rudy giuliani was at the heart of it
the president's lawyer
so there were people on the left that
say boy this really stinks of
some sort of uh disinformation campaign
with rudy working with the russians
there were ex-fbi xcia people signed a
letter said it looks like a russian
disinformation campaign
what do you think of the way this has
all happened and developed
well i mean russia it's funny how
everybody's a talk about russia now
it didn't used to be that way and maybe
it's good overall but
it seems like the whole russian
disinformation was just a nice way of
having an
alibi to shut out any media attention
frankly and
the the recent media attention the
recent disclosures that there's an
investigation
that started with the biden camp
announcing it and so to me that's really
interesting i mean if you're
representing hunter biden
and you know there's this probe that
could touch on a number of different
federal statutes money laundering
taxes uh foreign agency registration act
and
foreign corrupt practices act if you
know that's all out there and they've
got your laptop and they've got a grand
jury up and running
then to leak out information now
suggest to me there's something big
happening soon well then we found out
that the attorney general
had information or they knew things
before the election but didn't want to
tell people
is that he's in a tough situation right
if he discloses it in october it
he'll get criticized by people on the
left if he discloses it after the
election which he's done
he's criticized by people on the right
it's not an easy spot no it's not and
you know
i'm going to step back and just say when
i was at the department of justice there
were probably
i think i served under five different
attorney generals
starting with reno and ending up with
lynch and i would put barr
up against any one of them i think this
is a guy who has conducted himself
the right way during a number of very
tumultuous times
anytime he does anything that has a
political benefit to the president of
course
the left you know is going to besmirch
him as a toady and as somebody who's
just doing political things
but prosecutorial ethics dictate that if
you're investigating somebody
you don't go out there and announce the
evidence or the fact of the
investigation i mean that's why
one of the reasons the democrats hated
jim comey for a minute was because of
what he had to say about hillary and the
evidence there
so there's he really did what's exactly
right under
prosecutorial ethics and i find it you
know kind of amazing that people are
turning on them yeah it would have been
nice politically for the president
for the hunter biden story to be
actually covered by the media
but that's no fault of bar he did the
exact right thing on not
releasing information about a pending
case all right let's talk about john
durham
because when he was brought in and then
later
given the special counsel status this
was to investigate the origins
of the russia investigation correct
right um
you know as it turned out it wasn't just
a situation where the president wasn't
going to be
indicted but it turned out that the
investigative techniques
from jim comey and various points within
the fbi and
possibly extending in the doj into
political realms
they were very suspect they were using
politicized information they were
weaponizing the fbi to do political
bidding
and so there's a lot to look at there
and and john durham has been the guy to
do it and i think a lot like the
attorney general this is a
a career public servant somebody who's
not on a political timeline and somebody
who's just interested in getting to the
bottom of things
president trump always called the
special counsel's russia probe a hoax
and witch hunt
the fbi director he fired james comey
has defended that investigation into
attempted russian interference in 2016
and said after closed-door testimony in
congress in september
the president of the united states is
lying about the fbi
attacking the fbi and attacking the rule
of law in this country
but jim trustee isn't convinced there
was no political motive
citing the cia director at the time but
not particularly i mean if you look at
the paper trail that we've already seen
in this case and that's
very different than a paper trail that
john durham would probably look at
you know you've seen moments where even
john brennan's intelligence folks are
telling jim comey hey that russian
dossier is nothing
that you can rely on and it turns out
the dossier's origins
were en entirely political so there's a
lot going on there that it could have at
least
corrected itself during the fisa process
in other words when they would go back
to the court
and re-up as they call it their
applications that's when you clear the
air if you've made mistakes and so
by the time the second and third
applications were taking place
the fbi management i don't mean to rank
and file beyond
agent struck but the fbi management knew
there was wrongdoing heck you've even
had
an fbi general counsel plead guilty to
falsifying an email
that went into the fisa application so
there was a lot that was wrong
under comey's regime never mind all the
media leaks and the self-serving
narcissism but there was a lot that was
wrong with this investigation that
needed to be looked at and i think
durham's the right guy to look at it
now you talked about the fisa
application this is for carter page who
was a former
trump advisor in the campaign rather
low-level guy but he never has
been charged with anything right conor
page right and i don't think he ever
will be
and in fact i think it was probably not
even of serious
interest in charging him now not every
counter espionage
or counter-terrorism case leads to
criminal charges i get that
but this looks like it was more of
getting the camel's nose under the tent
to get information about the trump
campaign and then the trump early days
of transition
rather than building some sort of case
against carter page do you think
that john durham as special counsel as
as the as the biden presidency takes
over in 2021
what is the special counsel status and
how does someone get rid of it what
if the what if the president biden was
like this is just a waste of time
it's it's water under the bridge let's
get let's forget this stuff well the
special counsel statute
builds a little bit of tenure a little
bit of protection into it where congress
gets involved
if you are making essentially political
decisions or political firings so
there is a notification requirement
where if the president through his
attorney general wanted to get rid of
durham's probe he'd have to do that
i think what's really interesting is up
until recently there was never going to
be a report you know we heard people in
the media saying well what about the
durham report where is it
i mean never mind he lost six months of
grand jury to corona virus
well now there is going to be a report
the special counsel appointment
basically means at the very least
at some point probably early next year
john durham sends a detailed prosecution
memo to the attorney general and of
course the attorney general has to share
it
with members of congress and what we saw
last time was
the public interest basically led
attorney general barr to release it
to everyone and so the precedent is to
release this type of information
uh to the world at large and we'll see
how that plays out in in coming months i
suspect
you had referenced hunter biden in the
same breath
as john durham what does the special
counsel
doing the russia probe have to do with
hunter biden
well nothing right now and it would
probably be an entirely different group
in terms of special counsel and any of
the people that the special counsel
brought on
the issue is when you have special
counsel it's basically because you don't
want executive branch
prosecutors that are looking into
matters that affect
their superiors whether that's the
attorney general or the president for
instance
so it makes a lot of sense if joe biden
is going to be president
that his son's investigation wouldn't be
scattered between a couple of
u.s attorney's offices and wouldn't even
be handled by a politically appointed
u.s attorney
but would go to somebody with special
counsel designation so we haven't seen
that yet i'm not sure it's coming
but it's there's some logic to it just
in terms of how you normally
form out these types of sensitive
matters to people outside of doj
well it would make sense that that would
happen during
the president current president's tenure
right
not something that say president biden
would
appoint right i mean i i would be
shocked
uh even if it's completely meritorious
i'd be shocked if a biden administration
appointed special counsel
so again that brings us back to the
attorney general barr
leaving and leaving the department in
the hands of
the current deputy attorney general who
will become
the acting attorney general jeff rosen
the attorney general announced he's
leaving
the same day the electoral college
formalized joe biden's victory though
president trump still insists he won
they cheated like nobody's ever cheated
before
and they got caught just like the spying
on my campaign got good
that was again the president talking to
fox's brian kilmeade we've proven it
but no judge has had the courage
including the supreme court i am so
disappointed in them
now president-elect biden says it was a
free and fair election and the failed
trump
legal challenges were unprecedented they
refused to respect the will of the
people
refused to respect the rule of law and
refused to honor our constitution
attorney general
barr upset the president last month
telling the ap
he had not seen widespread fraud on a
scale to undo election results
remember this was a few weeks ago and it
was a very i think very intentionally
precise statement saying
we haven't seen enough information to up
overturn the election at this point
it wasn't swearing off you know a change
ten minutes later or ten days later
and the reality is criminal
investigations into things like election
fraud
take time it was never going to be the
vehicle to overturn this election
compared to the civil litigation where
you're going to court and trying to
affect the way the electors are selected
is there anything really left for the
president to do
to stop joe biden from taking office
january 20th
yeah that's a good question i mean the
problem is there's well maybe not a
problem but the the
difficulty in assessing that is there's
a lot of litigation still going on
it's just not always stuff that had the
president's party
you know the president's name on it or
his lawyers so there are things that are
still happening and
moving around in michigan for instance
and perhaps in wisconsin
but it seems like uh you know the clock
is running out or maybe it's ran out and
what's left if you don't go through the
court system is essentially
state legislatures deciding that they
will not
send the biden electors because of their
disgust at what happened within their
own state and of course as of yesterday
that seems to have not really happened
so
there's still technical availability
here before i guess congress accepts the
electors but
it's uh it's getting pretty thin
jim trustee former department of justice
prosecutor partner at the ifra law firm
in dc thank you very much for joining us
sure thanks for having me
[Music]
[Applause]
this is cal thomas with your fox news
commentary coming up
less than two months after the november
election the political world has
descended
on georgia people need help and they
need it right now
president-elect joe biden holding a
drive-in rally in atlanta on tuesday
to campaign for the democratic
challengers and a pair of runoff races
that will decide control of the u.s
senate i need two senators from this
state
i want to get something done not two
senators
who are just going to get in the way
because look
getting nothing done just hurts georgia
to win the senate democrats rafael
warnock and john ossoff would have to
flip
both seats held by republicans kelly
lefler and david perdue
none of the candidates hit the 50
threshold needed in november to avoid a
runoff
as early voting began again on monday
senator lefleur telling fox and friends
georgia is the firewall to socialism we
have to hold the line here
not just for georgia but the entire
future of the country rests on these
races
lefler's challenger warnock also says
there's a lot at stake
health care is on the ballot a livable
wage is on the ballot
criminal justice reform is on the ballot
facebook announcing late tuesday it will
lift its temporary ban on political ads
in georgia only we've seen now the early
vote
numbers the number of people who voted
in person
at polling places around georgia and
that number is
more or less like what it was before the
november election
arnon mishkin is director of the fox
news decision desk
i'm not anticipating a turnout level the
way we saw in
november in georgia but i am
anticipating a record-breaking turnout
for
a special runoff election in georgia and
one of the reasons for that is because
number one
over 400 million dollars in television
advertising time apparently has been
booked
between now and january 5th in georgia
across georgia so
i suspect it's hard to watch television
in georgia without seeing an ad for one
of the four candidates running in this
runoff
and the second is because the stakes are
clearly very high
i think that the republicans can run on
the idea that if the democrats win these
two seats
that they will get control of the senate
and if they lose at least one of them
or the republicans win at least one of
them that the republicans will have
control of the senate
and i think that that is a major
motivator for voters across the state
not necessarily because they really care
about um
mitch mcconnell versus chuck schumer but
because they do care about you know
their issues and whether or not their
issues will be able to move forward or
not
yeah interesting even even without the
presidential race
in the mix that issue of fighting for
control of the senate
um would appear to be resonating then
what about president
trump's claims of a rigged election in
november do we know
how much that may be affecting the
georgia race especially among
republicans does it you know to make the
base more motivated or less motivated to
turn out
i i think that's the sixty four thousand
dollar question there are clearly some
elements of the um group that's been
contesting the results of the election
that are telling georgia republicans to
boycott the race
i think that's a splinter group even
though that some of those people have
been
be tweeted by the president or or what
um
you know we we have not seen yet any
data that suggests
that the republicans are divided on that
issue um but i think that's something
we're going to have to look for between
now and
election day whether or not the
republicans figure out a way to
articulate the
you must vote in order to prevent the
democrats from winning
or whether the um those who don't want
either of those two republican senators
to win re-election
uh are able to say boycott the race
because
that's your best way of showing support
for donald trump
um i imagine there are a lot of
democrats who are hoping that that's
what it's going to be if i were running
one of those campaigns
i wouldn't be counting on it yeah
republicans are
trying to paint the democratic
challengers as being too radical
as well is that the
is joe biden really the counter to that
the president-elect you know campaigning
for those democratic challengers
on the ground in georgia on tuesday he's
seen you know largely to be more
moderate
is appealing to centrists you know is
that a good strategy is that why he went
there
i i think that's without question why he
went there i mean clearly
his life as president gets easier if the
democrats control the senate um
and so i think that's why he went there
and i but i think the question you're
asking is exactly the right one
i think i mean let's look looking back
on november november was a good day to
be a republican
so long as you weren't named donald
trump i mean the republicans won almost
every contested senate race that was
happening
they did very well in the house of
representatives um
it was a good day to be a republican and
i think that the republican message that
got out in november and that
sold across the country was the notion
that the democrats are
too liberal too radical what have you
and i don't think that the democratic
campaign the biden's campaign or the
individual senate and house campaigns
were able to respond to that effectively
and so that's been a winning issue for
the republicans
and i'm not certain it's enough for joe
biden to say look at me do i look like a
socialist
uh to counter it and um
[Music]
so it's clearly been a good issue for
the republicans
on paper don't the republicans have a
numbers advantage
in georgia still and is either one of
these races you know closer than the
other
the polling data today is very squishy
and
both both races and i've seen polls are
within the two or three points of each
other
um i think if you look at the numbers of
people who voted democratic
or voted republican in november in
either race um the numbers the total
numbers across all the candidates were
roughly 50 50 maybe 51.49
so these are both very very close races
i can't say that
any of these four candidates have a
distinct advantage
over the other you know any of the two
republicans have an advantage over the
other one
or any of the two democrats have an
advantage over the the other democrat
um i will say this uh
i think one of the challenges speaking
as a professional politician
all four of these candidates are frankly
sub-optimal
um they all have some negatives that are
that are that provide significant
challenges to them individually
you know in in the case of the
republican candidates in both cases
there's questions about their stock
trading and their
uh sort of focus on the senatorial job
versus their own
personal finances in the case of the
democratic candidates
uh john ossoff is a little young and
he presents his little young and that
that causes him i think will cause him
some trouble
and reverend warnock as you know the
whole history of many of his sermons
which may cause him trouble in january
so you have four sub-optimal candidates
i think if in the days of the bosses um
probably
they would have said is there anyone
else we can run instead of these guys
uh and um you know only time will tell i
think that
you know we are going to see um
in a state that seems to be increasingly
purple um
the likelihood of a really close race um
and the likelihood of
the results being um may take a couple
of days to find out is
is is pretty high on the other hand you
know
the the fact that the republicans lost
in november
is sometimes the best motivator for your
base to get out
i'm wondering how much all the money
being thrown at this races
will really matter because it didn't
seem to help
democrats beat republicans down the
ticket in november for house and senate
races
you're absolutely right in november all
that money that the democrats raised
didn't help them um you know they
thought they were they had a really good
chance of winning the senate they didn't
they thought they had a really good
chance
of winning some house seats they lost
house seats uh
so yes money is not um not what it once
was frankly
particularly when you're talking about
the numbers you're right right now
talking about which is you know in
excess of 400 million dollars
the thing i do think we want to look at
in georgia is the
importance of organization and the
ability of
either party to go not necessarily door
to door
or text message text message or
email chat to email chat to sort of
reach out
identify their voters and ensure that
they either
place their ballot in the mail or get to
the polling place
either one of the early polling stations
or an election day
and i think that's going to be decisive
um sort of which
which of the two parties is better able
to do that
um in in november i think a lot of
credit went to the efforts that stacey
abrams
had made over the years first in her
campaign to the governorship which
failed
and then in in november to elect
joe biden which succeeded and i think
she's going to be under a lot of
pressure her
team is going to be under a lot of
pressure to try to make sure that
machine works again
on the other hand republicans have
generally speaking been well organized
in georgia um i suspect that this
despite
all the problems that governor kemp is
going to do everything he can to try to
elect
the republicans despite all the tension
that is
was built up around the recount in
georgia because i think he needs to show
that his team
and his his uh organization is still
strong
and is going to be capable of leading
him because he's going to be running for
reelection
in just two years and i think he needs
to show that that organization still
matters if he's to win
some six weeks or so after the november
election
there's a new fox news poll that found
voters feeling
hopeful relieved or embarrassed those
were the top
three answers out of a range of emotions
about half of trump voters surveyed
those that they're willing to give joe
biden
a chance so could this georgia race
help the country turn a corner that's a
really interesting question um
ask me on january 7th i think it depends
in part
on on the results of that georgia
election
and it depends in part on the results of
of what happens with now that the
electoral college has
counted its vote and when the official
account takes place in early january
it depends on sort of what the reaction
is to that
i do think that you know that fox news
poll said many republicans are willing
to give joe biden a chance
on the other hand many of the
republicans also said they were
angry about the response to the election
and i think that means angry about joe
biden's victory
and what that means to me is those
voters in georgia
i think they're going to come out in the
polls and i think they're going to be
voting for the republican
and republicans and i think that that
will be
very helpful to those campaigns but what
it means in terms of
president biden or president-elect biden
only time will tell
fox news decision desk director arnon
mishkin
thank you so much for your time thank
you for having me
i'm guy benson join me weekdays at 3 p.m
eastern as we break down the biggest
stories of the day
with some of the biggest newsmakers and
guests listen live on the fox news app
or get the free podcast at
guybensonshow.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
cal
thomas what's on your mind it isn't that
the alleged exploits profits and
questionable business deals involving
hunter biden and his father joe biden
were not known for most of this election
year much of mainstream media either
ignored it or put it down as right-wing
extremism
until now we've recently learned the u.s
attorney's office in delaware is
investigating hunter biden's tax affairs
and has been doing so since 2018.
according to the associated press a
person familiar with the matter said
quote
the justice department's investigation
scrutinizing hunter biden's taxes
has been examining some of his chinese
business dealings
among other financial transactions
unquote
hunter biden disclosed news of the
investigation himself last week
he said in a statement quote i take this
matter very seriously but i'm confident
that a professional and objective review
of these matters
will demonstrate that i handled my
affairs legally
and appropriately including with the
benefit of professional tax advisors
unquote why is this investigation just
now coming to light
where has the media been all this time
even attorney general william barr
mocked by historian neil young as
trump's real personal lawyer
reportedly sat on the news of the biden
investigation
as the wall street journal reported last
week barr has known about a disparate
set of investigations involving hunter
biden's business and financial dealings
since at least this spring
a person familiar with the matter said
and worked to avoid their public
disclosure during the heated election
campaign
why wait until after the most important
presidential election
possibly in u.s history to now reveal
all
would the outcome of the election been
any different if media and bar had come
forward sooner
the media research center a conservative
watchdog group
conducted a small survey of seventeen
hundred fifty voters
in seven swing states it found one in
six who voted for joe biden would have
changed their vote had they known about
stories
the national media didn't cover mrc
concluded if that figure had been
applied nationally
it would have changed 17 percent of the
vote and trump would have handily won
the election
the greatest power the media have is
ignoring stories and depriving the
public of information they have a right
to receive
so they can make informed decisions this
was perfectly revealed in a statement
about the new york post story
when npr's managing editor terran samuel
said quote
we don't want to waste our time on
stories that are not really stories
and we don't want to waste the listeners
and readers time on stories that are
just pure distractions
and quite frankly that's where we ended
up this was a politically driven event
and we decided to treat it that way
unquote
but now media is reporting on the biden
tax investigation
after the election after voters made
their choice with half the information
necessary to do so competently
and they wonder why trust in the media
has been declining for years
as have their tv ratings and sadly
newspaper subscriptions
we're now getting revisionist reporting
from the same media outlets
that relentlessly pursued russian
collusion in the 2016 election
impeachment and the mueller report among
other stories designed to damage the
president
and separate his supporters from him
which didn't work
as his rallies have shown it's no wonder
trump's base agrees with him about the
election's outcome
it isn't just about the number of
ballots cast it's about censorship and
suppression
but the investigation into hunter
biden's tax record should continue
and the media should be reminded of
their failure to pursue them sooner i'm
cal thomas
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news go to
foxnews.com
from the fox news podcasts network in
these ever-changing times
you can rely on fox news for hourly
updates for the very latest news and
information on your time
listen and download now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your favorite podcasts
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes